[Musique]
la réunion détient la quatrième classe
des départements les violences faites
aux femmes sont les plus élevés pour
rendre le plus efficace possible les
différents dispositifs mis en place par
les pouvoirs publics la ministre les
outre-mer a tenu à les rencontrer
des échanges se sont déroulés à la
gendarmerie et à la sous préfecture de
saint benoît un territoire de l'est
particulièrement touchées par ce fléau
bien grenelle dans ce grenelle quelles
sont les spécificités outre mer le
grenelle autres maires doivent
abandonner effectivement faire des
propositions pour qu'on l'intègre au
plan national
quelles sont les spécificités quels sont
les lieux où on pourrait expérimenter où
on a déjà d'ailleurs expérimenté des
outils et la seconde sera local c'est
une nouveauté il est c'était une
implication des maires des sept mers et
son set 7/6 2/6 mer pour pour cette
lutte et nous avons aussi un engagement
fort sur le logement l engagement du
département sur les moyens humains
d'accompagnement notamment d'avoir
effectivement des agents qui viennent
accompagner au quotidien ces femmes
victimes de
de violentes des agents sociaux et a
besoin de 15 sur le territoire le
département vient de doubler le nombre
en est à 8
eh bien écoutez on progresse sur les sur
les besoins n'est là pour effectivement
permettre aux personnes de se sentir
moins seul quand elles arrivent dans les
services de police et de gendarmerie
quand on sait que c'est pousser la porte
d'une d'un commissariat ou une
gendarmerie c'est pas simple est arrivé
comme ça à parler de soi à parler des
violences à parler de ce qu'on vit à la
maison c'est vraiment pas évident et se
faire accompagner et se faire accueillir
par une personne en fait qu'ils soient
pas spécialisés mais qui skie qu'ils
sachent bien en fait
comment l'orienter comment la prise en
charge en fait de ces personnes là c'est
quand même assez intéressant les
assistantes sociales qui passe de 4 à 8
un engagement du département aux côtés
de l'état alors que vient d'être lancée
à la réunion le grenelle des violences
faites aux femmes nous allons doubler le
nombre de travailleurs sociaux en lien
avec les services de police et de
gendarmerie pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
est essentiel c'est l'accueil des femmes
qui ont été victimes de violences et cet
accueil doit être améliorée c'est ce que
nous allons faire à travers donc les
huit travailleurs sociaux qui seront
mises à disposition des forces de police
et de gendarmerie tout simplement pour
savoir écouter dialoguer avec ces femmes
qui ont été victimes de cette violence
le département souhaite également
développer des actions de
sensibilisation autour de la non
violence dans les collèges ainsi que
développer des espaces d'écouté
d'accompagnement au sein des pmi pour
les femmes victimes de violence avec
leurs enfants
[Musique]